all right welcome back let's go back to
the phones uh you can they're not really
phones anymore they're really internet
tubes
um
davidpakman.com discord is where you can
find it let's go first to shailen from
dc is that washington d.c
hey yeah can you hear me yes i can
hey yeah so i had a quick question about
the recent comments from
general flynn and
donald trump uh with the recent them
basically saying like oh that i support
a coup and all that yeah how do you
think this is going to play out for
elections in the next couple years
seeing like january 6 was a thing
and i guess just like election election
integrity being a huge thing on the
ballot like how do you think this is
going to play out for democrats in the
coming years well i think that
there's
we it's hard to say in the coming years
because there's so many variables but at
this point republicans aren't even
pretending to care about election
integrity or the rule of law all they
care about is what laws can we pass or
what laws can we ignore
so that we win
and with the news that donald trump now
is telling people he thinks he'll be
reinstated as president by august
michael flynn saying we should we should
do a coup like in myanmar or minamar as
the person in the audience called it
when they asked the question um what
what really is going to
shape the future of i mean like right
now i'm mostly thinking about 2022 and
2022 will influence 2024 it's what do
they actually pass in terms of voter
suppression and election suppression law
and they're trying to do a lot of stuff
in a whole bunch of different states
does trump starting up his rallies again
which we learned he's going to do
in order to probably support the people
he likes for 2022 does it inspire more
republicans to get out and vote or does
it inspire more democrats to go out and
prevent
another resurgence of trumpian insanity
but the in the background of all this my
fear
um is that this is going to inspire more
violence and at this point it's not
hypothetical i mean we know that they
can be inspired to violence because we
look at january 6th so when i see them
talking about a coup and trump talking
about being reinstated i worry about
more of the same and i think it's it's a
real scary time right now
awesome thanks for the answer all right
thanks jalen very good sounds like
you're getting a message there so i'm
gonna let you go
i've struggled with eye strain because i
do use my computer screen a lot for the
work that i do and there are some
studies suggesting that blue light from
screens can cause headaches or eye
strain watery eyes in some cases even
trouble falling asleep but i've had no
issues since i started using blue blocks
glasses which filter out that blue light
and they're one of our sponsors blue
blocks glasses are made in actual optics
laboratories with an evidence back
design they have readers a prescription
version non-prescription daytime
nighttime lenses 40 different frames to
choose from these are my blue blocks
glasses they've been great no more
strain from the computer with blue
blocks glasses filtering out the blue
light go to blueblocks.com pacman or
click the link below and there's free
shipping worldwide on orders over 115
dollars and until june 30th you'll
actually get 25 off orders over 160
dollars and 30 off orders over 315
dollars